I like the adirondacki jacket with the
tie and the shirt my mom got these for
Christmas so I'm just to make sure that
she knows she wants to text me about my
brother this morning I'm like I'm still
here you know
hi everyone it's time for the truth News
podcast where we're serving up all the
news you need a dash of Pop Culture a
splash of inspiration and always with a
side of good feels and today we're
covering everything from Rihanna's
upcoming Super Bowl halftime show to the
things that men can do freely but maybe
women get judged for well I'm here with
my co-pilot Rossi Ross Matthews hi Ross
you ready to go long that's a football
reference I knew what it was actually
gross
I know you're saying
well Ross that voice over there is the
very special guest we have joining us
host of the podcast Sunday conversations
and college football's first ever
supervisor of morale it's Caleb Presley
ready to go long ready I'm ready I for
sure I have to say I love the idea of
the what was it called the supervisor of
morale what what is that role so I
wasn't good enough to play
obviously you know you saw me already no
stop you're a quarterback yeah well I
wasn't but what were you technically
technically I was yes but in terms of if
I was on the field or not I wasn't okay
so basically I decided instead of
telling people I'm the quarterback and
they look for me on the field I'm like
I'm the supervisor morale And when they
see me slapping butts they're like that
makes sense oh Drew guess what it turns
out I didn't know
I didn't know morale too you
know yeah you really are would you be
kind enough Caleb to hit some headlines
with us I would love to oh great tell me
we have some football headlines well
first up Brianna just shared an early
glimpse into her upcoming Super Bowl
halftime show the 30-second trailer sent
the internet into a frenzy in it the
nine-time Grammy Award winner struts on
a dark Runway as lights flash this
halftime show will be the first time
Rihanna has done a performance in five
years yeah it's been too long where you
been what a comeback yeah well she's
been busy right she she had a baby and
she's the whole Internet's been waiting
for you as a baby like this during the
show right right I I just cannot get
enough of her I've been one of those
people waiting for this album and I'm
going to be drooling for this halftime
show are you gonna do you look I know
you're a big football fan like me but
you've got to be looking forward to that
how do you know I didn't tell you that
hello you're assuming you're assuming
things about it do you like the halftime
show you're assuming things about me
yeah but do you not like football I am
assuming that yeah I love it but you
were assumed I did yeah sorry and do you
like like show I do like the commercials
I love the commercials yeah I love Super
Bowl watching Super Bowl is like uh
super parties suck because you have to
watch it here you you can't have people
talking to you ever totally agree game
or commercial or halftime I know it's
like every second counts yes
yeah yeah so um are you a Rihanna fan
yes by the way I'd love to produce the
human that like does not like Rihanna
they don't exist well I was thinking
about this I was like when I saw the uh
her little teacher come out I was like
it has been such a long time she was
popular they say like your music period
when you're the most important music to
you is during your high school years so
that was for me that was Rihanna she was
part of that group yeah I was like there
probably are people who are watching
this like who is this no everyone
knows Rihanna I don't know I don't know
dude I have a uh my little brother's 10
years younger than me I don't know I
mean he knows who she is but I don't
know if she if he's gonna be like riding
for her songs you might think that she's
doing them uh was it she has a makeup
line or she has a Fenty I'm just saying
people have changed listen I'm telling
you right now I think because we have
been so waiting for Rihanna for so long
that it's going to be one of those
halftime shows that goes down in history
is one of the best like Prince when it
was raining remember I think it's going
to be that good like last year's uh yeah
I did like last year that would pay
homage to being in La I liked all that
West Coast
yeah I like Beyonce I like Gaga I'm
Gonna Love Rihanna see I grew up in Los
Angeles so I was so and rap music was so
important to me and in the 70s and 80s
when hip-hop and rap and all of that
came into the Forefront it's just it's
my favorite music and I was so excited
and so I was I was it really did it for
me because that is how I grew up and
where I grew up yeah and I'm a flaming
homosexual which is why I'm excited dude
what Rihanna yeah yeah we all we all
bring something to the table see I
didn't want to assume yeah you know what
you had a hunch and you were right oh I
love it all right next people on the
internet are sharing things they can say
that men do freely but women are often
immediately judged for things like I'll
give examples because I personally need
an example I heard this story and I was
like well what are the examples yeah I'm
curious all right here we go aging
having gray hair having body hair not
being in a relationship step oh that
would be me not wanting marriage or
children I don't anymore I have children
and I never want to get married again
going to a bar or a restaurant alone or
even being assertive in conversations
okay that one just pisses me off being a
sort of in conversations that that can't
be I hope to God that's not true all
right men thoughts well uh you you speak
for straight men because no I'm assuming
here we go
together man wow that's Caleb if he is a
heterosexual I just put you in a box um
I mean it's insane but I'll let it go
but it's insane do we have any straight
men here and maybe raise their hand if
we have anything
no I'm just saying you know yeah I
appreciate you not putting me in a box
you obviously did not raise him I mean
this is it this is insane the list is
insane you're right angry on that all
across the board a little bit Yeah well
because you know it's insane that's why
but there are things that people get
judged for girls get judged for guys get
judged for but um
I mean have you ever been a guy in New
York City trying to get into a club no
oh tell me whatever you like yeah have
you ever been a girl trying to get into
a club you're saying girls can just walk
in listen there's different things for
different people we all have our stripes
we all live our life with our Stripes
yeah that's a whole it's there are
things that are easier as girls their
things are easier as guys okay what's
easier for a guy uh the list is not
great but there are some things that are
probably true well let's go through so
aging aging is it easier for a man I do
look better when they get older that's a
fact and I don't I didn't make it up but
everyone knows that when old dudes you
look better than old ladies like if you
go into a retirement community there's
gonna be some hot old dudes not so many
hot old ladies so you're headrow and
into older men well well wow it really
shouldn't put you in a box wow I mean
that's that's unfortunately or
fortunately a fact age really badly
though I I I some people just about what
I well some I know the belt for sure I
definitely like what you mean like they
just that's right we'll see we'll see
we'll see I don't know I definitely
listen I grew up in Hollywood where
there is insane double standards and has
been for multiple Generations about how
men continue to work and women stop now
I think a lot of that's being addressed
and fixed and that everyone has a story
every human being on the planet
everybody wants those stories
represented and why is there ageism in
Hollywood so I definitely grew up under
the umbrella of this subject and the
scrutiny there for and the Crusade to
fix it so sure there are definitely men
who age better and some not and then
there are some women who look just I
mean that's true that's true they're so
beautiful and for me a lot of the ones
who look the most beautiful have not had
a tremendous amount of work done also
because that's to me a kind of a
different like age sort of you just
gotta take yourself out of the race once
you've had work done you can still look
hot but you take yourself out of the
race of who looks good and who doesn't
oh really I agree with that it's
different it's like it's it's playing by
different rules
and like I'm wondering like for example
like my hair is going gray and as a man
I feel zero pressure at all to die
you've never looked better thank you my
love thank you it's true I tell you that
all the time thank you but but my point
is it's like I've never had an executive
or uh someone on Twitter say you know
you shouldn't let your hair go gray you
look terrible do you but women I think
it's a different story like you know a
lot of my friends color their hair and
do they do it because they want to look
they like it that color and they want to
feel that makes them feel pretty or do
they do it because women are judged
differently than men what do you think
they are I think women are judged
differently more harshly or just a
different set of criteria I feel like
men and women are both judged
differently that's what I think I don't
know what do you think I I have to agree
I I do think women are judged more
harshly
um I also think there's an insane
standard like not to age not to gain
weight not to do this not to do that and
then you know Hollywood Fashion Beauty
can sort of perpetuate that however I
think we're in a moment in time where
body positivity
campaigns and companies and corporations
hearing the outcry from consumers and
people out in the world social media has
leveled the playing field
um in in many ways I think there is a
very new era that we are in that's much
more embracing
um and not saying like this is a beauty
standard and this is a beauty Norm I
think that rule book is on fire right
now in the SEC sexiest coolest of ways
totally I also think that it's hard I
look at every person on the planet and
they're so beautiful to me and then
every person for the most I see some
uglies
you know what I see some
ugly people on the inside and that
informs everything about the outside
it's like I don't care how hot you are
if you're a dingleberry as my daughter
now just learned that word you know what
that word yes I do I told her what it is
so she's like I want to make my nickname
dingleberries like can I tell you what a
dingleberry really is yeah yeah and now
now she just thinks it's the best word
totally yeah DB's DB
for dingleberry
um I've met some real dingleberries out
there like some real hot people uh quote
unquote and then they reveal something
about them on the inside that just makes
them so much less attractive and I met
some not typically hot people who are so
freaking dope on the inside that they
become so insanely attractive so I'm
definitely you know an inside out person
but I think we're in a new visual
standpoint where we're looking at things
differently and we've got our eyes open
and the periphery horsey blinders are
off and it isn't just sort of a cookie
cutter standard for people anymore and I
think that's a good thing a lot of
Social Media stuff has been kind of
insane in terms of like taking it too
far I think but I think it has what you
said it's open people's eyes so like now
you have to really you have to really
look at it Beauty I think is like if
someone's beautiful you can tell you
don't need someone to tell you what
beautiful is you can tell whether it's
there something you like about their
talking you're like oh this person's
beautiful or you can see them like this
person's beautiful you don't need
someone to
you don't need Vogue or whoever the
catalog is to be like oh this person's
beautiful now catalog a nice 80s
reference I love it I was trying to I
was trying to think of what what Vogue
does I don't even know it's like a uh I
still don't know I'm trying to think of
it but magazine yeah I haven't heard
catalog in a minute I need to tell you
what's beautiful like beautiful like you
know like this person's hot this
person's beautiful this person's you
don't need someone that's intrinsic uh
you naturally know I think I used to get
very excited the catalogs were all
people had you know for a sexy reference
used to get so excited what is a catalog
I actually don't even know it's like a
shopping magazine yeah yeah they they
wear the Fashions I would always look to
the underwear section yeah as a kid
because you're gonna get it acting up
dude yeah well I didn't have a lot in my
little farm town let me have the
underwears now it is not like today
where you can with the flick of a finger
I have access to everything catalogs
back in the day were literally like very
important I should get highlights you
guys get highlights I love highlights oh
my God it's a catalog
no you never order books no I just I
have to listen I want to welcome you and
agree with you but I have to disgrace
there dude it's a magazine you can't you
can't find anything from a highlight
where am I I'm laughing so hard okay all
right we'll be right back with more
[Music]
foreign
Presley up next variety reports that
Amanda Seyfried and Evan Rachel Wood are
working on a musical adaptation of the
1991 film and cult classic Thelma and
the week okay Amanda even missed out on
her acceptance at the Golden Globes for
the Dropout for which she won because
she said I'm creating a new musical and
variety reports that this probably was
it PR moved she should have went that's
what I think because she should have
gone you should if you're going to
possibly win an award you do everything
show up how many can you possibly win
Common Ground I'm with you if I'm
nominee for an award I'm sorry I'm sorry
but I'm gonna go just just on the off
chance my personal policies you don't
believe in Awards because it doesn't
matter if you win them but if you're
about to win one you go oh okay because
it's important if you win yeah what if
you're not gonna win you don't go okay
what how do you know if you're gonna win
or not yeah it's a good point
I was actually going to ask you because
if I'm ever nominated I'm not likely to
win so I was sort of curious it's true
but you know what I I do go and you have
one I have won a few very yeah I'm not
very nominated I'm not a big that's not
listen I have it too good I like I'm not
complaining yeah okay um what awards you
have no if you don't mind me asking
um I I I I'd like a Nickelodeon Kids
Choice Award did you slimed I did did
you really I did well that I got slimed
with the uh Charlie's Angels um I don't
think I ever got slimed when I won what
does it feel like to get slime is it
cold what's the temperature exactly what
you thought I knew I knew I knew that I
knew it was cold I've always wondered if
I knew it feels like cold vomit oh yeah
okay we'll be right back but you're so
like in the moment and it's so fun to
get like Nickelodeon slimed it's so
iconic that you're like bring it off and
they approve it beforehand or do you
have any idea the slimes coming you know
it's coming you know so you have a
change of clothes uh I didn't bring a
change of clothes that day I guess I
should have and does it get in the heel
does it get in the shoe oh yeah it's
everywhere wow okay so do you know the
movie Thelma Louise oh yeah
no okay oh I'm so good you have to wait
I have to tell you you would I think you
should see the movie about watching
Mamma Mia I see it on my scroll all the
time if you're gonna watch Mamma Mia you
and better than Mommy no different
different but if you were supposed to
pull the chicken Mamma Mia you know how
you scroll over something you're like
well and that's Amanda seyfred I love
her is it really yeah yeah and I don't
want to hate on Mamma Mia but I just do
have to agree with Drew you would really
love Thelma and Louise because it's bad
so cool yeah you should see that movie I
think you would love it in fact we want
receipts and reports Caleb will you
watch it I'll watch it first I'll watch
it fun pop culture homework I'll give
you like a one minute report yeah one
minute report please I'm not kidding
actually I'm happy to get a
recommendation because I'm always
looking for something Velma and Louise
you'll love it and I want to know which
one you are yeah oh they're two
different personality types yes I think
I'm more of a Thelma or Luigi I think
he's more of a Louise which is Susan
saranda agreed agreed oh
Gina Davis
sheesh I might be genitive you were I
just think you're gonna love the movie
so much and I can't wait for the one
minute report
two women are fed up and they take life
into their own hands very well said
Rossi thank you scandalous
Vegas it it is I'm not going to tell you
a single thing about it but it is
empowering and powerful and I just there
was nothing like it until that time and
there's never quite been something like
it since and a musical about like by the
way it also commits was it not a musical
the first time no no why say like that
because when you see it you're gonna be
like how would this ever become a music
yeah over the cliff over the class
you know what I'm actually in
negotiations toward the music
I'm gonna ruin it but yeah anyway
that'll be in the trades tomorrow all
right well a moving to Men's hairstyle
trends is long hair having a moment
immense fashion website fashion beans
compiled a list of the 30 best long
hairstyles for men in 2023 including
bangs side Parts braids mullets side
fades and even man buns
and you have long hair and you have a
man bun right yeah Sage gave me the list
before I came in here okay and he gave
me the 30 the list of 30. uh-huh I swear
to God all my life 25 of them are just
like long hair parted to the right long
hair particular long hairs long hair I
think yeah well where do you part yours
right now it's all pulled back I don't
no I'm not I don't want to be like the
front like the front man for long hair
because I literally grew it out and I
haven't cared since I barely wash it I
only wash if I'm gonna see Drew
Barrymore or you I will say it looks
very clean yeah because I washed it
I'm embarrassed to say this there's
there could not be less thought involved
Kelsey's my producer for Sunday
conversation which Drew's about to do
after this I'm so honored thank you and
uh so I put my I do my hair down for
Sunday conversation and then I always
say before I'm like because my hair look
crazy and sometimes she says looks good
I'm like let's go fire it up we look
good and she's like it looks a little
crazy I'm like that'll be funny too if
it looks crazy let me ask you a question
because I tried to do this thing on the
show called hair up hair down and I feel
like when my hair is down you know
there's one kind of um way I hold myself
a little bit well how I don't know it
just a little more loosey-goosey but the
second I get the hair up I feel like it
changes me like I get a little more
business like a little more you're mad
at dingleberry right now I'm mad as a
dingleberry
um you're grounded angleberry I you
dingleberry get over here I just feel
like it I don't know it changes my
demeanor yeah even when she does a high
pony which always gets me like in the
mood
um she's got this like fun acting up
today no no I mean like when she comes
on a high pony I know it's going to be a
fun day because yeah yeah
you're right I guess your hair it does
dictate your energy it does something
happens to me when my hair goes up it's
like all the Sass comes out and yeah I
just feel much more sharp what are you
doing on Sunday conversation do you know
yet what kind of hair are you going to
wear I don't know what should I do maybe
hair up yeah Caleb will you do a high
pony wait is this not high pony and it's
a high bun oh I'd like it no I've never
done a high pony in my life let's do it
now do it now hi Pony High pony High
pony I think a high pony would be great
I don't know how to do it okay may I
share it all right here we go so just
leave your head
to whip your lean forward for me or here
I can do it you can lean back oh wow did
you did wash today but I did hear a
rumor though the less you wash the
healthier your hair is and for the
record that's why I'm doing it I'm doing
a half up quick drill
Drew
she just whipped extensions out she just
cut her hair do you wear extensions
every day I didn't know this yeah what
little why don't you just take biotin I
I do actually it's not that much it's
just a little like a little filler like
a little fluff it out yeah that's even
different than the other energy you had
I need a ponytail holder you want me to
stand back there with my hand around it
I see what you're saying but in terms of
like the storyline I don't think I could
be wrong I don't think gosh think about
it unless it's the guy with it on the
side think about there it's on the side
if they get it cut on the side then
maybe they're thinking too much about it
and they just stop thinking about it can
I ask you a question I think that men
think about three things okay a lot like
women think about a billion things but
men think about three what are they can
we guess can we guess you go first you
go first wait let me oh oh that was not
where I was going that's not one of them
you were wrong I'm gonna write mine down
so that you know I'm not just let's all
write ours down let's all right that's a
fun game okay
so she's writing well why don't we
confer as the men here so so we're gonna
do what were you thinking tell me what
you were thinking and um
oh God think of the you think of the
third one
let's lock in on that I feel good about
these three I think and I feel like 75
sure that herds are going to match ours
yeah now that you've thought about it
her first list was not right no I just I
messed it up and I wanted it to look
graphically a desirable they say they
say the same thing I didn't change
anything okay and just to be specific I
think we should be saying a straight men
I think our list is specifically about
straight men I think so but I do all
right let's do it let's do it because it
would be nice let's do a modify list for
gays okay like the gay list okay ready
same number one yeah same number two and
the third one is Bravo
okay okay okay okay we're good all right
Drew oh do you wanna do you want us to
do our first yeah one for one one for
one okay oh yeah one for one smart yeah
our first one is sex okay we're gonna
lock in on sex I did not have sex on the
list that's an oversight on your part I
I'm I'm seeing obviously that that is
the case okay what's your number one
height she she's lost she's in a dog
place no it's that's bad that's not like
a Obsession of men is that they're
they're they're tallness or lack thereof
maybe short men I think short men maybe
think about it both of you cannot maybe
relate to that see I see I don't speak
for anyone other than myself okay which
is a smart way to do a PR right we have
a live one here yes I hear where you're
coming from and then okay uh this that
all right not that's not your first okay
here's our number two yeah okay so he
wrote this down because of the time
constraints I agree with them I think
it's a good point it's not necessarily
my number two he's writing a new one now
I would I would put this on the same
category all right money power job okay
like I think jaw yeah that would be my
number four okay well it's a list of
three number two
um hair
okay okay I think short bald men think
like you think
[Laughter]
the real chewy little center right now
okay okay uh and our number three and
you wrote this one
yeah I mean it's negoti I mean it's uh
could be disputed I would say boobs
I let him have number three sex money
and boobs I don't think that's your
number three oh no I'm good this is a
Bravo he said maybe when I was a baby I
was interested in them but now not so
much mine's penis
like they care about the penis size the
height I I think she's on to something
with that one and the hair and by the
way the next was gonna be like power and
money but I I think that's like fourth
but maybe for some minutes number one
yeah yeah penis could have been on our
list now that I think about it yeah
that's your list dude
what did you learn
um
you'll just have four on it well I added
the fourth because of the money power
Dynamic and I do think that that like is
some men's agenda can I do my three
because we kind of collaborated yeah
yeah I think I think it would probably
be in no particular order sex is going
to be on your top three Sports
too yeah that's in the top three yeah I
mean I think about figure skating all
day if you if you think like if you like
modern if you like saw every single
thought of a guy all day long they might
not think they think about it but I
think that they would have a percentage
of they're just thinking about their
their picks their gambling picks or
their sports or their sports team I
think that would be in the top and I
want to stand by boobs S3 okay yeah yeah
and sex
well sex is one right sex is number one
in a sports uh Sportsman sex sandwich
Sports boobs Sports as the meat yeah now
I'm hungry
and food what do you think about food
food's definitely a top three yeah it
would probably be sweet boobs food sex
boobs yeah that's easier can't boobs be
in the sex category no that's insane
because then you could have food sex
Sports and that really encompasses
everything but our maybe boobs are too
important to fold into the sex omelette
I mean listen I'm doing this for my guy
Glennie balls who you'll meet in a
minute
um I'm gonna put boobs in top three all
right
you heard it here all right last a woman
named Tina Holly recently went viral on
Tick Tock for using a power tool as a
bat signal to summon her husband to fix
things around the house Tina was sick of
waiting for over a year for him to
finish a project so she simply did this
oh she got it and he came calling I was
wondering women across Tick Tock are
using the bat signal of a drill to get
their house projects done
I thought you're about to fix something
no I was just using that's been on the
table if you just listen to this that's
been on the table the entire interview
and we didn't know why it was coming up
well now you know yeah I wanted to say
it was a power tool just in case people
are listening to this because it also
sounds like a vibrator I'm just going to
say which wouldn't make by the way in
the story this is where you guys don't
understand women if you heard this you
would not use it as a vibrator really
yeah I'm not exactly well versed on how
that works that you probably would never
be able to engage in anything again
so
all right good to see I learned
something five writers have a very soft
harm in comparison to that here's this
vibrator
oh yeah that does sound nicer different
yeah I have news you can use with some
takeaways
what do you guys think about the story I
think she was definitely using a
vibrator
I like that women now have a honey
that sounds like a vibrator again the
way you say it sounds like a totally
different story now that we're all
picturing oh you are yes I didn't even
bothered a picture yeah oh really now I
did listen I I have to I want to know
are you handy around the house can you
use a question thank you can you use a
tool my little brother's handy like I've
seen a handyman and I'm not I'm not like
him no way no chance I can do I can do
the main things you have to do set up a
TV yeah you can call somebody to set up
your TV yeah which can you set up the TV
or do you call someone to set up the TV
can I yes do I call yes okay perfect you
know on handy Drew I like to do it I
hang everything in the house I know you
do you are all man Rossi thank you
everything's well hung in my house
well everybody I gotta tell you this has
just been my cup of tea I love it I just
thank you Caleb so much for coming on
the show it's just been a pleasure it's
such a blast I'll call and I'll give you
my one uh one minute report
I would love to I can't wait to see it
also you could tell Rossi and I which
ones you think we are am I Thelma Louise
or is he Thelma and Louise okay I'll put
in the report all right fantastic and
the good thing about the report is I
won't see you guys so I can be honest
yeah totally we won't be staring you
down well thank you Rossi I love you so
much I love you
News podcast wherever you get your
podcasts and if you like this if you
like a podcast Caleb what's a good way
to tell people like I've said go tell
your cat you know or stop somebody in a
grocery aisle and share that information
with them what's your suggestion tell
your friends because your friends will
listen to you you stop someone to go
child they will not your friends will
listen your friends will listen Twitter
Falls they won't listen but your friends
will listen all right well then let me
just change that to tell a friend about
the Drew's news podcast and
um Quality programming I really like the
show well I'm very excited to do
um your show right it can't be too
excited
um that's our show and um as always we
make this for you so take it with you it
was fun that was so fun